You guys are probably never going to get tired of world war, two subjects.
And one thing I'm never gonna get tired of is my Vesey shoes,
which happens to be the sponsor of today's video.
And I'll take them off right now and show you. Look, do you like a good sneaker?
Well, something we call trainers in the UK. Do you like a good boot in winter?
Well, obviously this isn't a boot,
but the incredible thing is it acts like it because it's not just water
resistant. This is waterproof.
I shot some footage of me pouring a lot of water on these things and you can see
how it just flies off. It's pretty incredible.
Also offering unparalleled comfort and dryness,
regardless of the conditions outside. Now,
I hear somebody saying Simon I've had water resistant shoes before,
but having had water proof shoes, properly waterproof sneakers,
tapestries, trainers,
whatever you want to call these also easy to clean up and wearing them for a few
days. See this a little bit of dust on the front there.
We just wipe it off easy. It's made for something called [inaudible],
which is this really comfortable net that keeps you warm in the winter and cool
in the summit. Vessey has an incredible early black Friday offer right now.
So click the link below and grab yourself a Pat in your size before the upcoming
rainy season. When it gets underway. If you miss the salary,
you can use the code.
Biograph is a checkout and you'll get $25 off your next pair of shoes.
So let's head over to 20th century Britain for today's subjects.
If you'd been watching British politics in the early 1930s, chances are,
they would have been one name on your lips. Oswald Mosley was handsome,
charismatic, known for setting crowds,
alight with his passionate speeches and aristocrats with a huge working class
following.
He was perhaps the only politician able to unite voters of both major parties
regularly tipped as a future prime minister.
It was sad that he could one day be Britain's greatest leader,
but that never happens. Instead.
Mosley chose Jake his career down a much more dangerous path.
The path marked fascism as Burson's leading fascist Moseley was able to command
all. And he's a black Schutz. He received funding from,
with selenium was friends without off Hitler had the Nazis conquered Britain.
He would have almost certainly been made the ruler of a fascist UK state instead
of this one time, but let's go superstar story,
his career and reputation destroyed and the firestorm of world war one,
a joke to some, a dire warning from the past to others.
This is the life of Oswald Mosley. Hitler's man.
Bridget.
A man who would one day start himself a champion of the poor.
I was well Mosley's backgrounds couldn't have been more privileged born in
London on November the 16th, 1896.
He came from a family embedded in the aristocracy.
His grandfather also Oswald Mosley was a Baroness. Well,
his father also confusingly called Oswald Mosley was a rich Playboy. And yes,
that's way too many. Oswell Mosley's running around for one video.
Luckily the three Oswald's were mostly known by their family. Nicknames.
Grandpa Mosley was John bull. Well, baby noseley was known as Tom still,
despite his privileged status life wasn't easy for Tom Mosley.
His father was a serial adulterer bully who belittled his son, mercilessly.
The abuse got so bad that Moseley's mum board took the boy and went to live with
grandpa. John Balwyn. Tom was only five there. The boy was spoiled. Rotten.
John bull apparently saw Mosley as an ideal replacement for his own
disappointing son while Maude regarded him as both the son and to substitute
husband's calling him this old man Childs. It was men's affectionately,
but the image it conjures of a grown man,
acting like a spoiled kid would be speaky precedents.
The rest of those of these childhood past like that of any aristocrat before
turning Danny was sent away to preparatory school. And from there to Winchester,
he became a competent boxer and a world-class fencer before heading to sound
test at 16 to train for the military by now,
Mosley had grown into a tall athletic young man with movie star looks had also
grown into something of a colossal of Santos.
He became notorious for getting drunk and sneaking into town to pick fights
with,
or sometimes just beat up the little classes after one rowdy brawl with another
student, he was even suspended,
but he wouldn't spend long cooling his heels because the British military was
bound to need every able-bodied man.
It could get when world war one broke out in summer 1914,
mostly it was immediately recalled volunteering for the Royal flying Corps.
He trained as a pilot and by Christmas was flying reconnaissance over enemy
lines with airplane technology in its infancy. This was a dangerous job,
but it wouldn't be while on some urgent mission that Moseley sustained his
lifelong injury. In early 1915, Tom was doing training flights of shore.
And when his mother came to watch wanting to show off a mummy,
the man-child tried a difficult maneuver and send the plane crashing to earth.
It took a year of operations to save his broken leg,
even Mosley with a permanent limp. After that it was desk duty. Still.
This was no bad thing sent to work for the foreign office.
Mosley found himself in the London denuded of young men with Olympia could pass
off as a sexy war wound. And so while most men,
his age were fighting in the trenches, Mosley,
spenders evenings leaping into the beds of society, women.
And so he spent his days charming that rich and powerful fathers by 1918,
he was firmly connected to Britain's political elite.
And that was fortunate with the war over.
It was time for the UK to hold its first election. In years,
the election of 1918 is known as the coupon election because the coalition
government sent out lists of candidates.
It felt it supported the war efforts for public. Still flushed with victory.
Seeing a candidates name on these coupon lists was a sign that they were a
Patriot most coupon candidates on their seats.
I want to guess who managed to finagle his name onto that list? Well,
that December age, just 22,
Tom Mosley was elected a conservative member of parliament.
It was the beginning of one of the wildest political rise and falls.
The great Britain has ever seen.
If the previous decade had seen farting around enjoying life,
the 1920s would see them laser focused on advancing in May, 1920.
He strategically married upward. So do you sing the daughter of Lord Curzon,
the King and queen attended that wedding,
but it felt little love for poor lady, Cynthia.
Although she bore in three children, he was serially unfaithful.
So juicing both our sister and stepmother still treating his wife like trash
didn't stop Mosley star from rising in the comments.
He began attaching himself to a highly visible underdog causes.
When one of those causes was Irish independence.
His own party became so hostile that Moseley quit sitting as an independent,
but it soon find a new political home. In December of 1923 Britain,
second election in 13 months produced a shock outcome.
The conservatives lost their healthy majority and second place finisher.
Ramsey McDonald was able to form the first labor government in UK history.
Although it was a minority government momentum suddenly seemed to be with labor
in March Mosley the policy, and it felt like a shrewd career move,
but then came the snap election yeah. Of October,
1924 and Mosley watched in horror as the labor vote collapsed,
not only needed the conservatives win a landslide,
but Mosley lost his seat to Neville Chamberlain. It's easy to imagine.
Moseley now crawling back to the Tories, his tail between his legs.
That's unexpectedly, Tom,
that stuck with this new party over the next few years,
he underwent a rapid transformation from lay about TOF to outspoken friend of
the people he taught British slums,
where he deployed the condition of working class housing.
During the general strike of 1926,
he paid the wages of striking miners from his own pocket,
even traveled to the U S and spent time with Franklin D Roosevelt.
So the rumors,
he followed this with a trip to Birmingham and to meet a family of flat cap
bearing gangsters remained unsubstantiated.
The fall along Moseley was convinced,
had identified Britain's problems to his minds.
International finance was the driving force to the misery.
He saw all around him as he polished his speaking style,
becoming a master at whipping up listeners' emotions,
mostly began to preach that a command economy was the only way forward and labor
was the only party that could deliver it on this front.
It'd be sorely disappointed in the spring of 1929 Britain's election returns,
another near win for labor. Once again,
the party formed and minority governments by now,
and labor stalwarts mostly entered the new government.
Assuming it gets a plum post like foreign secretary when he was instead placed
in an advisory role outside cabinets,
he threw what could only be described as the man-child tantrum to end all
tantrums, but mostly soon realized his new job,
but designing schemes to stimulate employments the perfect inroad for his
theories as the great depression bit that Windsor mostly drafted proposals for
investment in public works for a protectionist market. Unfortunately,
the prime minister was less than enthused. Anyway,
1930 Ramsey McDonald got tired of all of Mosley's proposals and basically told
him, dude, your ideas suck. You suck angio.
Suckiness is making me look bad, just please stop it. It was the end.
So the lion for Moseley hands,
the governments shortly after Mosley resigned with a passionate hour long speech
in the commons that electrified the press in the aftermath,
people began openly saying that Moseley was right, that he was the fresh face.
You should be leading the labor party, not stuffy old Ramsey, MacDonald.
He was even tipped as a future prime minister,
his ideas being just the thing the country needed,
but Mosley's ideas were about to get a whole lot crazy.
Yeah.
And politics. They say that timing is everything.
And in 1930 Oswald Mosley was convinced his time had come across the, uh,
he sounded out labor MPS about a brand new party.
One far closer to the working people than McDonald's stuffy labor.
At the same time,
he courted conservatives with economic proposals grounded in exploiting the
Empire's colonies. When he published his Moseley manifesto,
people as varied as HG Wells,
John Maynard Keynes and future conservative prime minister, Harold Macmillan,
all expressed interest. Finally in spring of 1931,
Moseley decided to strike taking a donation of 50,000 pounds from a motorcar
magnate.
He used it to found a new populist party imaginatively called the new
party consisting of Moseley five rebel, labor MPS, and one rebel conservative.
It was a humble beginning,
but great things can grow from small seeds and Mosley stock was rising,
especially among those already feeling the depressions pinch.
It's not too hard to imagine how Mosley could have really seized. This moment.
Turn themself into the charismatic leader had always felt himself to be instead
of the young heiress to crash and watched in shock.
As that moment slipped through his fingers just as the new party launched Mosley
was hospitalized for six weeks with pneumonia.
By the time that did recovered the party's moments in the spotlight had already
come and gone.
The only ones still paying attention with the communists who were seriously
about the new party.
Stepping on that tough when Mosley tried to regain his momentum by holding mass
meetings and working class areas that the communists caused massive disruption.
So mostly hard protection again of hoodlums led by the boxer kid Lewis.
This would be the end of the new party.
The stewards Lewis recruited were young tough men who were super enthused about
beating out the commies.
And that's the era hardcore anti-communists tended to be on the extreme, right?
As more of them joined Mosley's army,
it was hard to waive the smell of fascism away,
but the deadliest blow came that summer with the country in chaos, Ramsey,
MacDonald abandoned his minority administration.
Instead he embraced the conservative and liberal parties in a national
governments. When he put this new government to the electorate at one,
the biggest landslide win in UK history. The new Pallinti by contrast,
didn't win a single seat in the aftermath of his humiliating defeat,
Mosley abandoned regular politics. He went to broad looking for inspiration.
His first stop miscellaneous Italy.
Although the new party had flirted with fascism.
It wasn't until Mosley saw a genuine fascist state in action that he fully
embraced far-right politics shortly after Mosley was at a party when he got
chatting to a young woman.
Most of these new passion for fascism blew the girl's mind.
She fell madly in love with him.
That young woman was Diana Mitford and meeting Mosley would change her life in
autumn 1932 Mosley at last did the inevitable, the British union of fascists.
So B U F was founded on October.
The first surrounded by former new party thugs decked out in black shirts,
Mosley declared his true colors to the world.
It was the final end of Oswald Mosley, the man who would be prime minister.
And it was the beginning of Oswald Mosley. Britain's most dangerous fashion.
Awkward.
And the summer of 1933,
Diana Mitford and a youngest sister unity traveled to Nuremberg to witness the
Nazis victory rally by now,
Diana was both Mosley's mistress and a hardcore fascist fan girl,
but soon she and unity would be something else too. In Germany,
they would become close friends, but that I've hit that back home.
Dan as lover was already modeling himself on Germany's new leader,
B U F rallies became Nazi tribute acts complete with lightning bolt flags.
See how salutes and Mosley ranting on stage like a man possessed.
At the same time, the party was deliberately targeting young, violent men,
luring them in with sports events and Malcolm rotary,
then preying on their grievances to radicalize them. Yes, at this stage,
no one in the British establishment could see the danger people in 1934
genuinely admired the B U F future King Edward.
The aides wanted Mosley to be prime minister. The daily mail ran headlines,
declaring hurrah for the black shirts membership at 50,000 people for a while,
genuinely looks like Mosley's brands of British Nazi-ism might have mass appeal
and then came the Olympia rally held on June the seventh,
1934 at the Olympia arena.
The rally was meant to be the biggest BOF meeting yet it's with Moseley holding
court before 10,000 spectators,
unfortunately planted among those spectators 500 anti-fascists who took turns,
disrupting the meeting and said it was almost impossible to speak.
The idea was to provoke a reaction,
which they certainly got Mosley's black shirts,
beat dozens of the protesters unconscious to the delight of that.
You committed fascists in the crowd,
but while the beatings played well in the arena,
the general public was much more queasy.
And the wake of the Olympia of islands newspapers withdrew their support for
Mosley. The BBC banned him from their airwaves by 1935, this old timey,
no platforming and seeing the bus shed 90% of its membership. Well,
there remains the real hardcore fanatics.
So Moseley began to ponder to them as hard as he could that year I did
35, the B U F adopted a validly anti-sematic platform.
We can't give you the worst examples of what mostly sad lest we trigger
YouTube algorithms and see yet another real videos get demonetized,
but Mosley openly called for the deportation of all Jews,
declaring Britain for the British were still,
he backed this hateful rhetoric with action on October the fourth, 1936,
there were 3000 black shirts marched into the Jewish district of Stepney in East
London. A show of force designed to intimidate,
although a vast ground of ordinary people blocked that path.
The March devolved into a rot that saw hundreds injured today.
A bachelor of cable street is seen as a turning point.
The moment Mosley lost the general public for good,
but at the time it was a victory for fascism Mosley declared the government had
surrendered to Jewish communist violence.
The U S membership immediately spiked burst by then.
Obviously he was already on his way to Berlin back in 1933, poor abused lady,
Cynthia, uh,
died leaving Mosley free to pursue his relationship with Adam Mitford.
Now they were taking things to the next level on October the sixth, 1936,
the two married in secret at the home of Joseph girls.
The guest of honor was out off Hitler who presented the couple with a signed
photograph as a wedding gift. Five days later,
200 youths from the U S flooded into Marland in London,
smashing Jewish shops and attacking anyone they thought to be Jewish.
It was one of the worst incidents of antisemitic violence in modern British
history, disgusting high points for most of these fascists.
Luckily though his career would be all down.
The biggest.
Against Mosley came just months after the battle of cable street that December
the national government decided it no longer gave a and bands,
both the wearing of political uniforms and the right to hold political
precessions at the same time,
the owners of venues across the nation agreed to bomb Mosley and the bur from
renting their properties. So they of course,
Moseley could just reach out to his fascist fan boys on Twitter or parlor,
but in the 1930s,
loss of venues basically meant losing all of your publicity.
And so Moseley vanished for a bit across 1937,
he was so far out of public view that he might've well,
I've just ceased to exist, but mostly it was nothing. If not determined.
In 1938, he has on a brainwave,
a way to resurrect the bus reputation among the genteel classes,
the black shirts would become avowed pacifists. By now,
it was obvious to everybody in Britain. This another major war was coming.
One very few people wanted to be a part of it was an arrow and the Chamberlin
government was pursuing appeasement.
When the prime minister could dismiss the Nazi invasion of Czechoslovakia is a
coral in a faraway country between people of whom we know nothing in such
circumstances.
It's perhaps no surprise that Moseley saw his popularity rebounds over the next
18 months,
Mosley cultivated a dove like image with the British public mass rallies were
held where he implored people to stay out of any future war.
These rallies were a moderate success by mid 1939.
There were even whispers that Moseley might be in the process of a political
comeback, but then the war arrived and the bus popularity,
again collapsed.
Although Mosley told his followers not to work as agents for Germany,
nobody believed he meant it. Indeed. As former deputy leader,
William Joyce had already fled to Berlin and began making Nazi propaganda runs
and the nickname, Lord,
there was no way the government was going to leave Mosley and his potential
fifth column running around free during wartime on may the 23rd, 1940,
just after Churchill became prime minister.
The U was banned and 800 of its members were arrested as security risks.
Mosley was imprisoned two months later, Dan and Mitford was also arrested.
The couple of signed photograph of Hitler was found in the baby's Crip that same
year they were interned together at Holloway prison.
And that was it for Tom Mosley's public career.
Although the pair were released on compassionate grounds in November, 1943,
it was to a general public that now considered them about as trustworthy as the
love child of Judas and Benedict Arnold.
The two stayed under house arrest until the Wars ended in 1945.
The moment they could, they abandoned ruins after an unhappy stopping islands.
The couple eventually wound up setting up a fancy house outside Paris from
Mosley, incessantly, plotted a comeback.
He reinvented himself as a passionate European calling for a United Europe to
ends the incessant cycles of bloodshed.
But while his pro Europe speeches were full of appeals to peace,
you only have to scratch the surface to see the poisons still lurking in his
veins. Mosley's declaration of Venice, for example,
suggested forcibly dividing Sub-Saharan Africa into black and white nations,
and then essentially using the black nation as both cheap labor and to captive
market for European products. At the same time,
mostly continued to rabble Rouse on hot button issues on one occasion,
while back in London,
he demanded the immediate deportation of all nonwhites from Britain and a ban on
interracial marriages. As a son, Nicholas wrote afterwards,
I see clearly that while all the right-hand delts with grandiose ideas and
glory, the left hands, that's the rat out of the sewer still,
and no longer really mattered what Tom Mosley sent in 1959. And again, in 1966,
the former political superstar stood for election as an NP,
both times he got so few votes that calling him and irrelevance would overstate
his importance after his 1966 failure Mosley officially retired from better
school life.
Although he edited a far-right magazine and captain sandwich with a vast number
of important figures,
well was that was essentially it for his influence on public life. Well,
at least until he turned up as the bad guy and Peaky blinders,
Leslie died on December the third, 1980 at his home in France,
cremated his ashes wearing ties and Paris is piano,
Shay cemetery far away from the islands nation.
He had once imagined he could lead for part time.
Mitford lived on in 2003 and all that time.
She never wants to express regrets for befriending Hitler or sporting Germany in
world war II.
Today also almost there's a little more than an interesting what FFA historical
footnotes off, and you can hang all sorts of alternate history ideas.
For example, maybe he really could have been a prime minister.
Maybe the new party could have really fulfilled its potential,
or maybe he could have stayed within the labor party and somehow deposed and
replaced Ramsey MacDonald equally.
It's easy to imagine a version of history where the Nazis succeeded in
conquering Britain,
a version of history where Hitler anointed Mosley as leader of a fascist UK
boil. It's easy to imagine a version of Oswell Mosley's life,
where he amounted to something that wasn't the life he led instead the historic
mostly, yeah, always remain a man who gambles big and lost everything, man,
who started out sympathetic, but eventually drifted away yeah.
Into a fog of conspiracy theories and antisemitism that put in beyond the pale
of all, but the craziest of British Nazis in the ends,
perhaps that's a fitting appetite for a man.
So full of self-importance to be remembered, not with, or not with fear,
but with mold, curiosity, and interesting failure at best,
it's comforting to know that we're mostly alive today.
This reputation is probably exactly what he wouldn't have wanted.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to check off fantastic sponsor Vesey link below and thank you for
watching.